I do a lot of work with the military and
I work with a lot of people who I would
consider great Patriots who are willing
to sacrifice for their Nations not
necessarily their lives but they
definitely make huge sacrifices they'll
never make huge money
um they are forced to uproot and move
their families on a regular basis they
travel and deploy and these are
sacrifices they're making for their
country they are great Patriots
unfortunately the word patriotism and
Patriot have been so politicized in our
modern day patriotism is a healthy thing
and regardless of what our politics are
I would hope that we all uh have a sense
of patriotism patriotism is simply
believing that our country is good and
striving to be better and even though we
are imperfect and do many things wrong
there is a striving and it is worth
sacrificing so that we can become the
best version of ourselves nationalism is
believing our country is better than
every other country on the planet and I
know what some of you thinking how can I
talk about that our country is great
when there's so much Injustice
yes I know that's why I say it's a
striving all people are created equal
were trying desperately to build that
world the opportunity is how do we
become better and what can we do as a
people how can we listen to each other
we are terrible listeners in this
country you cannot make peace with your
friends you can only make peace with
your enemies and every single one of us
has a responsibility even if we
vehemently disagree with someone
to give them a space to feel heard so
that we can feel heard and I think we as
a nation can do a lot better at sitting
in those difficult conversations as
opposed to avoiding them